[Applauso]
[Musica]
quindi un po di intimità poi lasciarmela
eravamo noi durante una nostra normale
giornata di lavoro da cinque anni a
questa parte e realizziamo candid camera
ed esperimenti sociali ed infatti la
frase che ci sentiamo dire più spesso è
io non avrei mai il coraggio di fare
quello che fate voi come se ci volesse
coraggio a stare seduti su un batter in
un ascensore
fatto sta che siamo per tutti i senza
vergogna se i nostri amici i nostri
parenti che le persone che ci seguono
sul web si chiama vi senza vergogna però
quando abbiamo ricevuto l'email per
partecipare al ted questa vergogna si è
fatta un po sentire si è trasformata in
una vocina una vocina fastidiosa che
nella nostra testa iniziato a dire cose
abbastanza simpatiche tipo quindi
andrete al ted a voi due
ma perché capita che sbagliano a mandare
e mail e magari era per qualcun altro
perché certa gente del calibro di
michelle obama quindi una cosa c'entra
teli e quindi abbiamo deciso di parlarvi
di lei michelle obama una persona
fantastica che mi ero preparato su
un'altra paura però noi abbiamo deciso
di parlarvi di quella vocina che ci
parla nella testa
nel nostro caso ci diceva non andate a
modena state a milano le andate solo a
rischiare su quel palco al ted che poi
voi non vi meritate nemmeno di stare su
quel palco e immagino che questa vocina
al abbiate sentito anche voi qualche
volta li nel centro della vostra testa
che cerca di tenervi fissi nella vostra
zona di comfort la vita è un susseguirsi
di scelte e spesso queste scelte ci
portano di fronte a un bivio con due
state completamente diversa dalla parte
abbiamo una strada comoda semplice che
non cambia il nostro status quo
insomma una scena stade da scegliere a
cuor leggero perché non cambia nulla
dall'altra invece abbiamo una strada un
po più difficile a scadere il
cambiamento e facendo quella scelta
diciamo rivoluzione un po altro modo di
pensare soprattutto mette in gioco te
stesso
ecco quello che vogliamo capire qui oggi
se solo noi sentiamo quella vocina anche
perché sennò andiamo in ospedale
psichiatrico e diciamo risolviamo la
situazione quindi vi coinvolgiamo ora in
un test per alzata di mano
se almeno una volta nella vita è
capitato anche a voi di sentire quella
vocina e di fronte a uno dei tanti bimbi
che si sono presentati avete scelto la
strada più comoda anche se vi portava a
cose già viste vi chiediamo di alzare la
mano a chiunque sia capitato almeno una
volta per esempio mi è capitato
ha però la comunità vedo che piace
sempre anche anche qui a modena e invece
vi faccio un'altra domanda se quella
volta dopo aver scelto la strada più
comoda ve ne siete pentiti perché vi
siete resi conto che era sì più comoda
ma vi ha portato a perdere delle
occasioni ecco se ve ne siete pentiti
vorrei vedere ancora le vostre mani
alzate anche a livello di rimpianti vedo
che siamo messi b ora continuiamo il
test parliamo di lavoro
quanti di voi almeno una volta nella
vita ha fatto un lavoro che che odiava
qualsiasi motivo magari no ma manuela
chiedo io è un pò giusto capitale
secondo te è un percorso si motiva
magari un ambiente poco stimolante
colleghi poco simpatici mansioni non
adatta alle vostre alle vostre capacità
a quanti di voi si è capitato dai tutti
abbiamo fatto meno una volta neri è e di
questi qua quanti sono andati comunque
ogni giorno al lavoro maledice libero
ogni singola mail che riceva le ricevute
soltanto per un singolo motivo perché la
vocina e loro testa continuava a dire ma
non cambiare lavoro ma che poi non ne
trovi un altro
guarda che poi sembra mancare in un
villaggio turistico con le speranze non
si paga le bollette non farlo
quanti in quanti ragazzi vedo che
diciamo anche a lavori sottopagati siamo
messi bene
ma parliamo ora di un argomento più
felice sogniamo un secondo parliamo di
amore quanti di voi in questo momento
sono intrappolati in una relazione ormai
finita scusano amore e la per teheran
se lo dice cosina la ferita surano hai
ragione aspirazionale quanti di voi in
questo momento stanno pensando ma guarda
cui due maledetti sul palco son qui di
fianco a mia moglie ti pare che possa
alzare la mano per l'amante viene
settimana prossima forse anche questa
sbagliata quanti ce l'ho ce l'ho
quanti di voi tantissimo tempo fa in
relazione precedenza le elementari con
un ex unes ma neanche l'ultimo ex e
tanto tempo fa avevano capito che
l'amore era finito eppure non avevano
lasciato perché nella loro testa una
vocina gli diceva ma non troverei più
nessun altro nessuno ti ti ti ti ti
amerà più ti ascolterà più non troverai
mai più nessuno che ti sopporterà quanti
di voi successo è successo era una
domanda un po più semplice ma che
richiede molta più sincerità da parte
vostra
quanti di voi in questo momento stanno
pensando
ma perché saltando la mano comando
perché su quel palco non ci sono io che
ho molte più cose interessanti da dire
rispetto a quei due
nessuno grazie l'aspettavamo davvero
volte più mai alzata e quindi vi
ringraziamo facendo v l'ultima domanda
del test di questo test ovvero la forse
la più importante quanti di voi almeno
una volta nella vita hanno pensato
questa cosa non posso farla ma non è
colpa mia sono timido io l'ho pensato
sono timido pensate che io ero un
bambino molto timido quando i miei
genitori mi portavano a vedere gli
artisti di strada mi mettevo sempre in
ultima fila perché ero terrorizzato
anche solo dall'idea che mi chiamassero
a fare l'assistente avevo questa paura e
da questo test vedendo le vostre mani
alzate abbiamo capito che questa
sensazione che noi abbiamo chiamato
vocina abbiamo provato almeno tutti una
volta nella vita e l'abbiamo provata per
un semplice fatto perché forse abbiamo
paura paura di fallire paura di
sbagliare paura di risultare stupidi di
fronte a tutti gli altri fine test non
preoccupatevi però volevo specificare
una cosa noi non siamo sociologi come lo
stava pensando per immagino di no però è
meglio mettere diciamo questo puntino su
questa hit ma vorremmo condensare tutto
questo discorso ha in due termini che ne
sono molto familiare ovvero timidezza e
stupidità il primo la timidezza ricevuti
mi dice lo siamo stati e alcune
situazioni lo siamo tuttora altre
stupidità non aggiungo altro
elise da un po e vogliamo dirvi qui oggi
che fra questi due termini esiste una
precisa correlazione e infatti siamo qui
per rivelarvi che la timidezza è
stupidità o meglio che un atteggiamento
timido è un atteggiamento stupido il che
attenzione non significa assolutamente
che chi è timido è stupido perché la
timidezza in sé è un valore anzi un
meccanismo naturale che ci protegge
dalle insidie del mondo esterno problema
è quando questo valore si trasforma in
un ostacolo e questo avviene quando
diamo sempre solo retta a quella vocina
nella nostra testa e quindi non ci
impegniamo non investiamo noi stessi
nelle scelte anche perchè abbiamo molta
paura perchè
possiamo scegliere di combattere questa
timidezza dovremmo investire tutte le
nostre forze dovremmo essere quelli che
lo siamo mai stati fino a quel giorno la
timidezza e stupidità quando ci
impedisce di prendere la strada giusta è
stupidità quando non ci fa rischiare è
stupidità quando la voce nella testa
diventa un urlo un nullo che dice io
sono timido non posso farcela
in questi casi la timidezza stupidità
questa stupidità questa timidezza
scusate questa timidezza che noi
percepiamo come un muro dietro quali
nasconderci dietro quale protegge c in
realtà è una catena è la catena che ci
tiene imprigionati qui nella nostra
comfort zone dove si siamo tranquilli ma
dove nulla può cambiare in questi
termini quindi essere timidi e stupidi
ora possiamo fare un esempio immaginate
di essere in una piazza affollatissima
magari un sabato pieno piena di gente e
fare shopping vede vincente è un vostro
amico o magari di sfida di sfida di
andata poi un urlo fare un urlo
fortissimo e mezzo alla piazza vediamo
che succede
come pensate no io sono timida una roba
del genere non la faccio poi la gente mi
guarda mi giudicano cosa penserà di me
un gesto così inutile perché dovrei
farlo però due passi insieme a nemico di
te ma sì dai
sa cosa faccio non do retta la vocina ma
e urlate in mezzo alla piazza
e cosa succede nulla figurati intorno
due o tre si sono girati qualche
surreali venuto un infarto
gli anni ormai erano primo gennaio oggi
non cambierà nulla ma in sostanza non è
successo davvero nulla e quindi capite
che quell urlo non era poi così inutile
perchè l'ha fatto capire che le persone
dopo due secondi hanno ripreso la loro
vita cioè non stanno a giudicare voi
quindi capite che tutto il tutto questo
discorso e per dire che la gente non
riguarda velocità il centro del mondo e
sono per per accusarmi di protagonismo
però hanno di meglio da fare
la sua è meglio da fare tra cui
probabilmente quel di non ascoltare una
voce nella testa che tutte le volte che
dice non fare possono fare con l'altro
perché questa vocina la sentiamo tutti
anche quelli che voi pensate
stiamo giudicando adesso non vorrei che
usciti da qui qualcuno vada a urlare in
giro non era questa l'intenzione vi
faccio un altro esempio per cui è valida
e valido comunque questo consiglio
immaginatevi questa situazione
ve la faccio al maschile perché sono
uomo tutte le mattine vi recate nello
stesso bar a fare colazione vedete
sempre lì che fa colazione una ragazza
bellissima la più bella che avete mai
visto vi piace se volete parlare
ovviamente non l'avete mai parlato
perché siete timidi e perché la voce
abbia tenuto ben lontani da un rischio
di rifiuto da dal rischio di una
delusione
ecco quello che stiamo tentando noi oggi
di dirvi è che dovete andare a parlare
ma dovete andare a parlare non perché è
la cosa giusta da fare ma perché è la
più logica
infatti se analizziamo la situazione con
un po di raziocinio ci rendiamo conto
che esistono solo tre ipotetici casi il
primo caso non andate a parlare a questa
ragazza
cosa succede niente cosa succede niente
state dove eravate non succede niente
nel secondo caso andate a parlare con
questa ragazza ea lei voi fate schifo
può capitare in senso capita non le
piace te cosa succede
questa ragazza mera nella vostra vita
prima non sarà nella vostra vita adesso
quindi niente
nel terzo caso ragazzi andate a parlare
alla ragazza e incredibilmente è
reciproca la cosa cioè le piace te e
quindi bingo ecco quello che stiamo
cercando di dirvi oggi è che la
timidezza è stupidità
dal punto di vista logico perché nel
peggiore dei casi agendo ottenete
esattamente la stessa cosa che avresti
ottenuto non agendo ovvero nulla ma nel
migliore dei casi con la ragazza al bar
non so se mi sono spiegato la terza se
capiti quindi essere timidi e stupido
quando vi fa vedere un ostacolo al posto
di un'occasione
in questi termini è stupido stupida la
timidezza
però ora vorremmo concludere il nostro
intervento qui al ted con un esperimento
sociale e vogliamo mostrarvi cosa
succede a dare retta questa vocina e
quindi ad arrendersi alla timidezza
quindi mettetevi comodi perché abbiamo
ancora qualche minuto ora ricominceremo
e vi mostreremo questo intervento una
nuova versione di questo discorso
quella che vi avremmo fatto se noi
avessimo ascoltato la vocina e ci
fossimo arrese la timidezza
ora ci prepariamo sono spegnere le luci
[Applauso]
[Musica]